some pretty mixed opinions tonight about
the proposed clark county school
district transition plan
the 205 page document was posted online
just last night and it outlines how to
bring
staff and students back in a hybrid
model a combination of
at home and in person learning but as
kristen drummond shows us
it seems to raise more questions and
give answers
now it's all going to get shaken up
again a logistical shakeup
one more set of massive changes many
remain uncertain about the ccsd
transition plan
the proposal divides students into three
groups two participate in a mix of
in-person and at-home learning
while the other cohort is full-time
distance education
i think the biggest concern is the
specifics are not there
carmen andrews is a ccsd teacher she
says this recommendation
causes concerns among educators it's
left very open to interpretation
and the way teachers read it is we are
responsible for everything
a big worry the hybrid instructional
model educators may be assigned to
teaching students in person
and online as well possibly at the same
time
the hybrid plan ends up in like triple
work for teachers there's still
not a lot of clarity regarding exactly
what the different groups of kids are
going to be doing
and what level of support they'll be
receiving rebecca garcia with the nevada
parent teacher association
also questions the secondary school
schedule students on campus
only attend two courses they must
complete the other half of the school
day
online whoever thinks that's going to
happen i mean like as a mom i'm like
yeah my kid's going to come home from
in-person school and log right back in
probably not
but others welcomed the district taking
this initiative i think they have a
really really
good plan in motion a plan to try and
reopen soon
kristin drummond 8 news now the board of
trustees will vote on the reopening plan
on thursday of course that plan also
contingent on any changes the governor
could make if cases don't go down with
the new stay-at-home order
in the next two weeks well the union
representing ccsd support staff released
a statement about that plan today
and the education support employees
association president
says at this point the timeline
presented by the district and their
reopening plan
is not workable with all of the changes
that have yet to be made to ensure staff
and
students are safe in our schools